I'm so excited for the show but welcome
to the show by the way Welcome to our
show have you ever met Kevin no I mean
of I'm a big fan of you nice to meet you
I'm a huge fan yours that was fantastic
thank you so much I'm so happy to be
here I know we are very happy to have
you I love the action pack little humor
in there too but I I'm going to start
with this because I just moved here do
you have a favorite eating spot cuz he
gave me some I've got a lot oh my God
I'm such a foodie person I'm always
looking for food like yeah I'm I always
want to try everything Pro my favorite
pizza spot is year rubirosa have you
tried that one when you sounds like the
sexiest St pizza ever sound
like have you had I not had it I've not
had it no but if I don't know I got to
know do you like look at me and ask that
question
again oh God okay you need to try that
one okay I love you so much yeah so you
grew up with older brothers right I do I
have one older brother were they nice
ones or did they have to toughen you up
or um right now we have the best
relationship but when we were kids we
were kind of like R competitive yeah you
know he's two years older so yeah yeah
it was a great it was a great a fun
relationship I heard that you also I got
family tattoos once with my sister and
my mother I heard you got family tattoos
oh I do yeah my symbol for my Ranch is
almost identical to that you are kidding
yeah there you go so those are my I'm
blown away right now I was like is that
mine
the same are you it's not this it's
there's an arrow at the top for mine but
like I was like what so those are or
initials so it's ector the H the L for
Liliana and R rata this is incredible I
got to show you guys this oh my God I
love I got this no no no no not this
body this body is clean clean that your
temple is free yes I love it um well
tell us about Zoro well I'm so happy
it's finally here we shot for eight
months in Canary iseland in Spain yeah I
feel that we've seen many versions of
Zoro but this one is a very modern like
fresh full of action diversity action
fightings um the thing that I love the
most about this new version is that
every single female role in the story is
very powerful and important and I feel
that that's something that we haven't
seen before in the other versions yeah
so I love that Lolita my car she's a
modern woman she breaks the stereotypes
she doesn't try to fit into like you
know like Society rules and yeah I feels
so proud of it I know it looks so good
I'm so I love anything action filled
with like a little humor and yeah I
think that we had a lot of physical um
training for that you know I heard wait
you ride horses in it as well yeah but
you're allergic to horses I am I
actually am it was my secret until I
booked the job cuzz I was like how did
they feel when you said I'm allergic to
horses all of a sudden oh God they
freaked out they were like this is not
happening like she's always with a horse
and I was like guys it's totally okay I
won't die I can breathe I mean worst
case scenario I would look like a
different person like which is kind of
not good like my eyes would go smaller
like my lips would go bigger but other
than that it's fine yeah you just take a
pill or something exactly it's fine oh
my I love actor it's the best thing I
never knew any before this show and now
Five Seasons In All of You Lie when you
say about the job it's like of course I
sometimes you have to do it no no not
sometimes all the time it's every actor
that comes on this couch is like yeah I
never done that before but it's like
yeah I hurdled in high school what like
it's like yeah they I it's fascinating
but it's very bold because then you're
just like yep I'm going to get on this
horse and pretend like I R of course I
was like I'm not going to lose these
opportunity because of Myer I was like
that's my secret yeah but then I
couldn't I couldn't lie to the doctor so
it was like so then the second season
what you do is when you gain all the
power and the shows doing really well
you just ride a uh a non like an
allergenic like a a poodle you exactly
exage that's a great idea that's a great
idea he's got ideas um well let's do a
quick commercial break everybody you can
see it an's horse allergy um in action
on Zoro it's available on Prime
[Music]
video
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home